Ladies and gentlemen my name is Professor Philip Goodman my job is to explain the unexplainable
untangle the truth from the fiction
You don't have to have your life ruled by superstitious fear
Mr Goodman, Everything you spent a lifetime trying to debunk the supernatural. It's all true
Three cases I couldn't explain you go and investigate if you dare
Things are not always as they seem
Tell me about your incident. you don't believe do ya?
Hello?
I don't need people looking me thinking that i'm mad because I know what i saw. no,no,no
Do you believe in evil professor? I didn't until that night.
Maria?
These are Signs. I know you're still there! the spirit.
I Understand how easy it is to get confused.
And then in thoughts get into your head man
Everything is exactly as it seems. You don't know everything.
Wait, wait! i don't like it.
The brain sees what it wants to see.